>>Joe Malin: Hello, and welcome once again
to Android Developer Office Hours.
My name is Joe Malin.
I'm your moderator.
To my right is Trevor Johns.
Beyond him is Jeff Sharkey and Reto Meier.
At the producer's panel is Robert Ly.
I can't think of anything else to say at this
moment except that our topic for today is
performance.
>>Reto Meier: More importantly, it's efficiency.
>>Malin: And efficiency, sorry.
Efficiency.
[indistinct conversation]
[video game music and sound effects playing]
>>Malin: Great.
Thank you very much.
Shout out your questions.
You can get into the Hangout and call them
in, or you can type them in, or whatever you
want to do.
For the moment, since we don't have any of
those from the Hangout, we're going to go
to Moderator and take some of the questions
that have been entered already.
The first question is: "Is there a simple
way to get distinct results from the contacts
provider?
I used a loader manager to bring the cursor
loader.
The cursor's past one adapter of an auto complete
text field, but I did dupes."
I will try to answer this.
If the person that asked this is online, I
would like to know more about exactly what
you're trying to do.
My guess is what you-- based on what you've
said--, you are getting duplicates because
there are distinct records in the provider
for the same person.
That's the way the provider is supposed to
work.
You will not--.
The provider is set up so that different versions
of the same person, from different sources,
are recorded as distinct records.
The duplicates are not eliminated.
What happens is they're aggregated into a
single record that points to all these different
versions.
>>Johns: Yeah.
For example, you could have your-- a contact
from your Google contact book as well as the
data that's retrieved from Google+, that the
user themself entered.
>>Malin: Right.
Depending on how you access the provider,
you could get a person's record based on their
personal Gmail, their work Gmail, Google+,
etcetera.
The documentation for the contacts provider
that's on developer.android.com explains to
you how to deal with that situation and get
the data that you may be looking for.
That's probably why you're getting duplicates.
If you were to look at all the information
in the records that are being returned to
you, you'd see that some of it was different.
>>Johns: Yeah.
I guess as a tip, stay away from the [indistinct]
contacts table.
Also, the data table is going to have duplicate
data as well.
But I believe the high level contacts table
should have a single representation of each
person.
That'd be a good starting point if you're
trying to read through the docs.
>>Malin: If you look at the documentation,
you'll see some examples of how to retrieve
different types of information from the provider.
And also, look at the things called entities.
What entities do is a behind the scenes combine
of different pieces of data that help you
do the sorts of things that you might want
to do with the provider.
But I definitely suggest you look at the documentation.
Anything else?
>>Johns: No, I think that pretty much covered
it.
>>Malin: Okay.
Next question: "What are some tips for file
manager UIs?
I'm currently writing an app that, although
it autosaves, its saved files and external
ones should be accessible to the user.
The file browsers on the store are in lists
or icons.
DPI is also a factor."
>>Johns: First thing.
Don't show the whole file system is my recommendation.
There's a number of file manager apps out
there.
For example, Astro.
They're good tools for power users, but that's
not the model we want for Android UIs.
We really want to say, "Okay, here's the documents
on your device."
We don't really care where they live, are
they on internal storage, external storage
in some subfolder.
All that's irrelevant.
We don't actually want to expose the underlying
Linux file system.
We just want to say, again, "Here's all the
docs we could find.
Go ahead and pick one and open it up."
If you're asking whether it should actually
be a list versus thumbnails versus some sort
of icon, I tend to lean a little bit more
towards the idea of either a list or a thumbnail,
and possibly even allow the user to pick.
If you have more [indistinct] state, thumbnails
are really nice.
But they do take up more space.
A good example, if you're looking at something
to model off of, would be Google Docs.
They do a really--.
Or Google Drive, excuse me.
They do a really awesome list view for displaying
files.
Because they don't have a folder hierarchy
by default, they have to go and do that fairly
well.
Of course, you still can create folders, and
they handle that, too.
I guess that's my advice.
It's really more of a UI question.
Without seeing your app, I don't think we
can give you one size fits all recommendations
here.
But I think that should be some good general
guidance.
>>Malin: Any other comments?
>>Jeff Sharkey: Yeah.
One thing to think about when you're building
a file browser like that: you're going to
have the different UI on phones versus tablets.
On a phone, you might end up with that single
list view where the user navigates deeper
into a file hierarchy.
You might be able to present the tree or the
file system tree on a left-hand side pane
using something like fragments on a tablet-sized
app.
Definitely depends on which size of device
you're targeting.
You might be able to fit more or less details.
>>Meier: I think generally, and I just want
to reiterate what Trevor and Joe have already
said, and that is, generally speaking, the
move has been away from having hierarchical
file structures to support your app.
It made sense back in pre-GUI days we had
to figure out a way to be able to put things
in a place you'd be able to find again if
all you've got is the ability to list the
files in a folder and what the current folder
is.
These days, the move is very much away from
that.
It's really more about tagging things, making
them more easily searchable.
You can see the way that Google Drive does
that in that your things just sit there.
You can tag them and you can search for them.
Same with Gmail, which was a forerunner to
that.
In most cases, if [clears throat] if what
you're building is just a file manager, then
I think it does have some value, if you're
figuring out how to put the file manager into
your app, to make it easier for users to save
files and load files.
I'd say that you're probably going in slightly
the wrong direction.
You should be thinking more about how can
you make it easy for people to find the content
that they're looking for without having to
navigate a hierarchy or a deducer.
>>Malin: Okay.
Yeah, I would add that the difference is that
if you use some sort of file hierarchy like
old-fashioned directories, then you're stuck
with putting one thing in one place.
Whereas if you tag it or give it some metadata
that you can then search on that for, you
can put something, so to speak, in more than
one place at the same time.
Kind of like the way that labels work in Gmail.
They appear sometimes to be folders, but they're
really not.
A message can be in more than one label.
It can have more than one label at the same
time.
That's a great benefit to users.
>>Johns: Yep.
Another thing to think about, too, we're just
speeding file hierarchies to death here, but
when you have nested folders or nested directories,
you have to go and click through all of them.
That's a pain on a mobile device.
It's a lot easier if you have a list.
You swipe, you tap, you're done.
Again, Meier touched on this: search is incredibly
important.
Make sure you have that in there.
I'd say it's more important than tagging.
If you can only implement one of these suggestions,
it would be search.
[pause]
>>Malin: Okay.
>>Robert Ly: We've got a question on the Hangout
here.
>>Malin: Okay.
>>Ly: "How do I go about creating a category
side view which takes only half the screen
when sufficient real state is available with
a pager title script, similar to what is shown
in Google Play?"
>>Malin: Okay.
The question was--.
Can people hear you on the Hangout?
>>Johns: Yes.
>>Malin: Okay, fine.
So you've heard the question.
>>Johns: I heard the question, but could you
repeat it, actually?
[laughs]
>>Ly: Sure thing.
"How do I go about creating a category side
view which takes only half the screen when
sufficient real estate is available with a
pager title script, similar to what is shown
in Google Play?"
>>Johns: Also, I know that in Google Play,
you can swipe.
I'm not sure what the side view is.
We're trying to pull it up here so we have
an example.
>>Sharkey: So you go up to the top level,
go into one of the categories--
>>Meier: Oh, categories?
Okay, so I'm going to go into apps.
>>Sharkey: Yeah, and pull left.
I think it'll even work in portrait as well.
>>Meier: And-- oh, cool
>>Sharkey: In one of the apps, like apps for
magazines.
>>Johns: We need to hook up our HTMI tablets
here so we can actually show you this.
>>Meier: Oh, I see, okay.
Let me just turn it around--
>>Sharkey: Demonstrate.
>>Johns: Yeah, hold it up to the camera.
>Sharkey: There we go.
>>Meier: Let's get rid of the glare.
When I pull and it stops halfway across.
And I can pull it back.
That's exactly halfway.
I presume that that's the functionality that
they are looking for.
Excellent.
Getting head nods.
All right.
That's a good question.
How would you do this?
I would guess that this isn't using a view
pager.
>>Johns: Or at least, it's a modified version
of view pager.
Yeah.
To my knowledge, there's no way, by default,
to ask view pager to do that for you.
There's another question a bit further down
on the question queue, too, which touches
on this, which is asking, for example, Google+,
when you tap the home button, you have a navigation
panel that slides out from the left.
Right now, there's nothing in the support
library or otherwise elsewhere in the framework
that really makes this easy to do.
A recommendation, actually, right now, it's
an awesome model.
I love it.
But it's not something we're actually actively
recommending to people because there's been
so much flux with these widgets.
Everybody's doing it a little bit differently,
so there's not really a single recommended
approach as far as our UI deadlines are concerned.
If you really do want to implement it right
now, you're on your own.
Over time, once we actually figure out what
the right way this should look should be,
we'll probably add it somewhere, support library,
most likely.
But that's a ways off, and that's assuming
that we actually decide we like it.
It's always possible we'll change our minds
later on.
Yeah, you're pretty much on your own, unfortunately.
From the technical respective, if you wanted
to place a start, I'd start with view pager
and start modifying that.
But it's not going to be as simple as setting
a property.
>>Meier: It looks, if we try and think this
through, it looks like what it's doing is
it's-- all the other interaction works exactly
the same as view pager.
If you started with that, and it looks like
all it's doing is saying if you're at N+1,
well, I guess at 1, then limit the size of
the fragment for the 0th fragment.
That would seem to be a place to start.
Have a look at the view pager.
What you want to do is modify the behavior,
if the first fragment is visible so it doesn't
fully extend to the full width of the screen.
I don't think we have any sample cuts.
>>Johns: Nope.
I'm not aware of any, either.
>>Ly: The person in the Hangout says they
looked into that using a view flipper in combination
with animations, but they could not figure
out how do they let the size-- not the view
flipper.
Reto's suggestion.
They tried what you--
>>Meier: They tried what I suggested with
a view pager, but they couldn't find out how
to limit the size?
Yeah, I think that's going to be the struggle,
because the way that the view pager is designed
is to effectively do the animations between
two set frames.
Instead of having those two fragments on screen.
The other possibility that you may want to
try is to have the 0th fragment contain--.
What you're actually looking at on that view
pager isn't actually the lost fragment being
half width?
It's just that the last fragment looks like
the previous fragment and the first fragment
joined together, if that makes sense?
I don't know how you would do the animation,
but maybe once you get halfway across and
then it switches it.
I see it's getting a little bit hairy, even
in my own mind.
We'd be interested to see how you get on,
but I don't think there's an easy solution
for that at this point, unfortunately.
Like Trevor says, the best chance in terms
of getting something relatively straightforward
is to wait and see if we or anyone else creates
a standardized widget that does something
similar to what G+ and YouTube did.
>>Malin: Okay.
>>Ly: Okay, we got another question on the
Hangout.
>>Malin: All right.
>>Ly: "I'm looking for tools or methods that
will help me test my app in extreme conditions.
For example, low memory, low disk space by
CPU usage and", in parenthesis, "that is done
by another process."
>>Malin: Hmm.
Okay.
>>Johns: At first I thought here, extreme
conditions.
Are you going go and try to drop it in a volcano,
launch it into space, take it over to Antarctica?
Space has been done, by the way.
We actually have launched Android phones into
space.
But I'm not aware of any that have gone into
volcanoes.
Seriously, though.
>>Sharkey: Challenge accepted.
>>Johns: [laughs] Anybody know a good volcano
nearby?
>>Sharkey: Sounds like an excuse to go to
Hawaii to me.
>>Johns: Some of the things, like Slow Network
in particular, there's support for an emulator.
Now, low disk space, I'm not aware of any
really good automated ways to go and test
that other than writing a script that goes
and dumps a bunch of files onto your SD card.
I know there are some third party companies
that make some test suites that do go and
test some things like what happens when the
battery gets low.
Off the top of my head, I believe Testdroid
is one of the ones that can do some of this
stuff.
I don't think it can do everything on your
list, but it's worth looking into.
That's by a company called Bitbar.
They offer a subscription service where you
upload your APK to their service and they
run a series of tests on devices you've supplied
to them.
Oh, sorry, on devices they've supplied for
you.
You don't have to mail them any devices.
That's probably your best bet if you're looking
to try and do a lot of this short of trying
to go and automate a bunch of it yourself
using things like ADB to go and--.
Actually, ADB will only get you so far, even.
If you're trying to test low battery, you'd
have to hook up some hardware and start modifying
the voltage.
It's a tough one.
Really no easy way there, other than what
the emulator already provides.
And it does supply some of it, so definitely
look at that first.
>>Sharkey: One of the tools that can potentially
be really powerful is the Monkey, which generates
a bunch of random events.
Touches on the screen, keyboard event inputs.
It'll push your app in all different directions.
We use that a lot on the team to help uncover
bugs in all of our apps across the platform.
It'll generate a lot of that noise.
It'll uncover race conditions a lot of times
in codes.
The Monkey tool is great.
You can find it, it's just using ADB on the
command line.
>>Meier: Similarly, if you're trying to simulate
these extreme conditions based on what our
other apps are doing, the easiest solution
in a lot of cases is going to be to create
your own version of those other apps.
The extreme conditions are going to be when
other apps are misbehaving.
You get to have fun and create an app which
is really poorly behaved and does everything
that we tell you not do to.
It chews up memory, it causes other apps to
effectively swap out and get killed.
>>Johns: I think we actually--.
I think, was it Dianne Hackborn where we actually--.
Something very similar to that for an internal
use for a while.
[laughter] Our own builds had a very badly
misbehaving app installed on them for a bit
to go and try and test what happens when apps
misbehave.
Thankfully, that doesn't chip.
[laughs] I think that's probably a good approach.
Just write a really bad app.
That's going to go and cover, at least from
the performance side of things, what happens
when things go wrong.
>>Meier: That's usually the easiest way to
do it.
You can do a lot through simulating things.
But ultimately, it's going to be "How does
my app behave when another app is using all
my bandwidth, using all my processors, using
all my storage?" is to build that other app.
It gives you the control as well, because
then you can decide how far you want it to
go.
"At what point does my app start being unresponsive?
What steps should I take to try and help the
system out?"
>>Malin: Any other comments?
>>Johns: Nope.
>>Malin: Okay, thank you, gentlemen.
Now let's move on.
Oops, I think I skipped one here.
"I have a fragment which uses a loader that
implements the loader callbacks.
I have set retained instants true for the
fragment so that it is not destroyed across
orientation changes.
However, the loader it creates in the on create
loader gets reset.
Why?"
[pause]
>>Johns: That's a good question.
[laughs] Actually, I've never seen this behavior
before, so I'm not sure what the answer is
off the top of my head.
This also, I think, was one of the later questions
to come to the queue, so I didn't get a chance
to research it beforehand.
Yeah.
I actually do not know the answer to this.
[pause]
>>Malin: No?
>>Sharkey: Hmm?
Yeah, don't know.
>>Malin: Okay.
>>Meier: It seems strange.
>>Malin: Well, the panel's puzzled.
>>Johns: Our usual advice, if you can go ahead
an post the question on Stack Overflow, we
try and take anything that we can't answer
after the show and get an answer for you.
Just go ahead and drop a comment on the G+
post, pointing to the Stack Overflow question.
We'll try to get some more detail for you
after the show.
>>Meier: The other thing that I'd want to
mention, for this one in particular.
Set retain instant state fragments is awesome.
But generally, it's designed to work specifically
for fragments which don't have a UI, which
is a perfectly good place to put a loader.
One of the things that I've mentioned is a
word of caution: if you are using that on
a fragment with UI, that may be causing the
problem.
I'd need to look into more detail.
This is something which is vaguely tingling
in the back of my mind.
But generally speaking, the set retain instant
estate property is designed for UI-less fragments.
>>Ly: Got another question on the Hangout.
>>Malin: All right.
>>Ly: "I have a performance question related
to databases.
What are the overhead implications with SQLite
and increasing the number of tables?"
>>Johns: Hmm.
That's a good question.
I'd say adding more tables probably is not
going to hurt you too much.
What is going to hurt you is joins and, at
some point, just having so many records that
it takes a while to iterate through all of
them.
Setting indexes wisely is definitely going
to help.
Indexes to increase the costs when you perform
a write.
It's a trade off.
In exchange, you get faster read times.
I'd say that's pretty much where you're going
to see most of your performance, is trying
to do joins and trying to iterate through
a lot of records or searching on fields that
don't have an index.
That sort of thing.
Adding more tables should be fine.
Performance impact: minimal.
>>Malin: Any other comments?
All right, let's move on.
"In the past, I've used an Intent Service
to load data from a REST web service, but
I saw that in the new Google I/O app that
Async loaders are used extensively.
Is loader currently the recommended way to
load remote data?
When should Intent Service be used?"
>>Johns: Okay.
I think this one's in a bit of confusion about
the way the I/O app works.
Using an Async loader to go and pull data
from a web service doesn't actually sound
like a very good idea to me.
We actually don't do that in the Google I/O
app.
What we do do is we have a background service
in conjunction with a sync adapter, which
goes an fetches the data from the web service,
stores it in a local database.
Then that loader is used to go and fetch the
data out of the local database.
That's the model we're using.
It's nice because we don't have to worry about
trying to fetch data while the apps are running.
Everything's already cached locally.
In the background, we actually can send a
GCM message to the phone, informing it that
the schedule's changed.
Then it can go and update the conference schedule
in the background.
That way, every time you open the app, you
don't have to wait a couple of minutes for
the latest schedule data.
You know you always have the latest data right
on your phone there, already stashed.
As far as the other half of the question,
which should entail when should Intent Service
be used?
I think, in that case, partly it's a matter
of convenience, what's easier for you.
Intent Service is still going to run as a
service.
We're still running as a service.
It's just-- Intent Service is more, if I remember
correctly, because I've actually never used
that one myself, but I think that's more for
one-off jobs.
You specify a request instead of an intent.
Whereas in this case, since we're always going
and doing the same thing over and over again,
we're always fetching these schedule changes.
There's really, I think it works better, it's
just a self-contained background service.
Reto, did you have any comments on when Intent
Service is a better choice?
>>Meier: Yeah, actually.
Me and Joe have actually been talking about
this for the last couple of weeks.
I think, if you're looking specifically between
Intent Service and Async Task, I think that's
generally the sort of question people have.
Often, you'll come across the Async Task class
first and see it as a really convenient way
of being able to do background stuff.
You want to get off the UI thread for it to
work in Android.
It's great.
It does all the marshaling to the UI thread
for you, which is really, really handy.
That's a clue as to when it's most appropriate,
as well, so there is some overhead associated
with it.
What it's really designed for is doing something
within your activity which is going to have
a direct impact on your UI.
If it's something which is allowed to get
destroyed as soon as your activity gets closed,
because remember, of course, that your Asynced
tasks within an activity, as soon as you rotate
the device, they're all going to get killed.
It's really stuff which should not be long-lived.
It's just too time consuming to do on the
UI thread.
Intent Service is just a really neat way of
being able to encapsulate one of the most
common service implementation patterns.
Service is basically designed if anything
within your app which needs to live longer
than the average lifespan of a particular
activity instance.
Anything which needs to live across multiple
activities, anything which should stay, continue
to be active when you're rotating the screen,
all that sort of stuff should live in a service.
Anything which you are downloading which is
more than, anything nontrivial which you're
downloading probably wants to be in a service.
The Intent Service is really handy because
it creates this queue for you.
It'll basically create a serial queue where
you keep sending it commands to do and it
will keep going through them until all the
tasks have been done, and then innately kill
the service for you.
If you're doing things like intermittent downloads,
as Trevor says, anything which is going to
be on a regular schedule, anything which has
to happen on an ongoing basis, should probably
live using Async adaptor.
But if you're just going to be downloading
things when a user clicks something, so you
don't really know when it's going to happen,
then Intent Service is perfect, because you
can send it the things.
"Ooh, I want you to download this."
It will download it.
When it's finished, it updates your content
provider, and then your UI automatically gets
updated by its loader when the content provider
associated with it has been updated.
It just helps to create that nice pattern
for you.
Often, that's the way it works, as well.
Intuitively, when you first get started with
something, you have an activity, you have
a UI.
There's a temptation to just do everything
within that class.
That's the trick behind Android, that your
main form is actually made up of your activity
plus the service support plus potentially
a content provider as well.
You really need to think of all of those modules
and how they fit together in order to create
something that works in the best way.
>>Malin: Thank you.
Good answer.
[laughter]
>>Meier: Thank you.
I need to take a beverage to moisten my mouth.
[laughter]
>>Malin: Any other comments?
>>Sharkey: The one other value of Intent Service
is really, if you're in your UI and you want
to persist something, if you really want to
make sure that it gets saved, that's what
Intent Service is used for.
Even if the user hits that home key or gets
an incoming phone call, if you've kicked that
off in an Async Task, there's the potential
that your process gets killed, and that data
may not be saved.
So if the data is important, send it off to
that Intent Service.
If it's something that's important to persist.
>>Malin: Yeah, that's a very good point.
I would add that it's really great for being
able to go send off some work to be done,
allowing the user, then, to go off and do
any other task that may come up.
So that if a phone call comes in or the user
wants to go off and do some work and wait
for this thing to finish, they can go do that
and then get a notification or some other
indication when the work is done, and then
go back to the activity.
Okay.
Let's move on.
>>Ly: Another live question.
>>Malin: Shoot.
>>Ly: "Is there a way to use a different class
loader at development time, not necessarily
for production for services?
It looks like it's possible to do this for
activities using instrumentations and new
activity methods, but I'd like to do this
for all parts of an app."
>>Malin: A different class loader.
Okay. [pause] The only thing that instrumentation
does, really, in terms of loading classes,
is that it allows you a little bit of extra
control or injection into activities.
There's instrumentation available for services
and for content providers as well as for activities.
That's the only answer that I can give, myself.
I'd be curious to see what the use case is
to know what the answer would be.
>>Johns: I know it definitely is possible
to specify a different class loader within
your activity.
When you start going and firing off other
things like creating a new service, creating
other activities, I think you have limited
control there.
But I know there definitely is a way to go
and control things once your activity has
gotten started.
Unfortunately, it's not a very common task,
so I can't remember the way to do it off the
top of my head.
But I know it definitely can be done.
For example, I know there was some talk a
while back of trying to use this as an investigation
mechanism and encrypt classes and do all sorts
of other fun things like that.
Again, not something I'd do or recommend most
developers try and concern themselves with,
because lots of pitfalls lie down that road.
But it definitely is possible.
>>Ly: So he basically says, "I want to load
the activity itself with another class loader."
>>Johns: Right, that's the question.
Oh, the activity itself.
I don't think that's possible.
I think the best you can do is load classes
within the activity, because activity startup
is not something that you can control.
By the time you have control, your activity
has already been loaded.
>>Meier: Could you do something within the
application object?
If you created your own application--
>>Johns: Well, except, when you get a chance--.
Well, then you'd have one before your activity
is actually created.
>>Meier: Yeah, the application will--
>>Johns: It will get it maybe slightly before.
>>Meier: The application instance will get
created before the activity.
>>Johns: All right.
Ahh, maybe.
It's worth a try, but I don't think any of
us have ever attempted to do that.
>>Meier: It doesn't seem like a very good
idea.
>>Johns: No, it isn't.
Like I said, lots of dangers when you start
messing with the class loader.
It's usually something I recommend people
to stay away from.
Also, it's a little odd.
We've been getting a lot of questions today
that are text only.
You guys are welcome to go and hop on video
chat or audio.
Just let Robert, our producer, know.
He'll make sure that you'll get patched in
live to us.
We can actually talk to you face-to-face.
We're more than happy to answer text questions,
too, if you don't have a camera.
[pause]
>>Malin: Okay.
We'll move along to the next question on Moderator:
"How to create the drop down slide in navigation
from action home up button?
Is it as convoluted as all my Google results
indicate?
Or is there a simple way to do it?
Google+, YouTube, and Spotify incorporate
this feature."
>>Johns: I think we already answered this
one earlier.
But just to reiterate: yes.
It is as convoluted as all your Google results
indicate.
On that note, also, we don't recommend, really,
pursuing this until we have a recommendation
as part of our design guide, or at the very
least, if people start coming up with some
libraries to do it.
There's really nothing out there that makes
it easy yet.
That said, if you'd actually like to go and
write the first library to implement this,
I'm sure there's lots of developers that would
thank you.
But right now, it's not something we can really
recommend people do unless they're really
adventurous.
>>Meier: I'd also point out, as well, if anyone
does decide to take Trevor up on that challenge
that the--.
So each of these different implementations
you mentioned are slightly different in the
way that they work.
That's part of what Trevor's talking about,
is that there isn't a real consensus based
on the star guidance to the right way.
That said, the consensus seems to be heading
towards the YouTube model being the right
way of doing this.
If you do want to implement something similar,
look at the way the YouTube app has implemented
it and head in that direction.
But for now, it's definitely not for beginners.
I think it's going to be a little bit tricky
to do.
>>Malin: Okay.
>>Ly: We have a live video question.
>>Malin: Go for it.
>>Johns: Yay!
>>Malin: Fire away.
>>Ly: Thank you.
Give me a minute, here.
>>Malin: Are you on--
>>Male #1: --where we have an ad with a button
next to it to launch in an app purchase, but
every time we don't give the ad view the full
width of the layout, it freaks out and says
it can't display the ad.
But even if we create a VM that has a really
tiny screen that is equivalent to what space
it has, it will display the ad as long as
we give it match parent or fill parent.
We're trying to figure out how we can solve
this.
Right now, what we're thinking about is making
a fragment that it was allowed to take full
width of, but I'd like to not complicate the
layouts too much, if possible.
>>Malin: Hmm.
Okay, so to repeat this, you've done an ad
that you want to display with a button next
to it to do something like in-app purchasing.
>>Male #1: Correct.
>>Malin: Okay.
And every time you try to set that up, it
complains because it says you don't have enough
room to display the ad.
>>Male #1: Correct.
>>Meier: Interesting.
So the ads are coming from a third party provider
like AdMob or something like that?
>>Male #1: Yes.
AdMob, to be specific.
>>Meier: [laughs] Okay.
Interesting.
This is only going to be an issue on certain
size of displays.
If it's, say, a phone where the AdMob banner
is specified to be the right size to fit best
with the full width of the phone, then you're
going to have that issue when you try to put
something next to it.
Is that right?
>>Male #1: Yeah, except for if we create a
virtual machine that has a width in pixels
of what the view would be expanded into, as
long as we don't put the button there, it
works fine.
So we know that that amount, that real estate,
is sufficient to display the ad.
>>Meier: Gotcha.
That's interesting.
While we think about that, one thing which
I would mention is that you need to be really
careful when you try to create something like
what you're describing.
One of the requirements we have in, I think
it's our developer content policy, is that
you shouldn't be putting ads anywhere where
a user may accidentally click them.
Putting ads right next to a button, which
you want people to press for any reason, may
actually be in violation of that, because
it would be very easy to get confused and
accidentally hit the ad instead of the button,
or--
>>Male #1: Then how does Pandora get away
with it, because I hit those ads all the time.
>>Meier: [laughs] Yeah, fair call, fair call.
I can have a look how the Pandora app works.
Like I said, I'm not--
>>Male #1: Should we display the ads behind
the interface buttons?
>>Meier: [laughs] That doesn't sound awesome.
I can't comment on other apps and what they
may or may not be doing wrong.
It's just something which has come up at least
once before with a developer I was working
with who ran into some problems on that basis.
I'd be cautious.
You basically want to have any of your interactive
elements as far away from your ads as possible
to avoid running into those kinds of issues.
>>Male #1: Okay.
I see Keys mentioned something about not being
able to place ads, or buttons close to the
ads.
Is that possible the API is seeing that and
causing a problem, or--?
>>Meier: That's actually possible.
I hadn't considered that.
But it is possible that the actual AdMob API
is looking and seeing, "Oh, you've got a button
right next to the ad.
That's not kosher."
It does seem a little strange.
I'd be a little bit surprised if it was smart
enough to do that on your behalf.
But just from a UX perspective, if nothing
else, I think it's really not best practice
to have your interactive elements that close
to your banner ads.
>>Male #1: Right, okay.
Regarding an in-app purchase button, would
that be something like in the overflow of
the action bar that would be recommended?
>>Johns: It depends on what you're buying.
It depends on the nature of the in-app purchase.
>>Male #1: It's like the premium kind of model.
>>Johns: Okay, so basically it's an upgrade
for your app that adds additional features.
Yeah, the overflow menu is certainly one option.
The downside there is discoverability , right.
The idea behind an overflow menu is you never
see it unless you really want to go looking
through it.
A better idea is just to go and put a--.
When users get to the part of the app where
they try and get to the premium features is
where you could start promoting the upgrades.
Have the right controls available.
Then when you click on them, you could pop
up a dialog, saying, "This is reserved for
a pro version."
Or you could have an entirely separate screen
with all the controls disabled and say, "Click
here to upgrade."
Probably a better idea just to go and display
the dialog as soon as they click on the button
that takes you to that part of your app.
I still would have an option in the overflow
menu to go and apply the upgrade for people
who know that they really want to get to it
to keep them from having to dig.
But definitely look at other opportunities
for upselling.
Try and figure out how users will know that
there's actually additional value, that it's
something they want to buy.
>>Male #1: All right.
Thank you.
>>Johns: Yep.
>>Meier: Thanks for your question.
>>Malin: Anybody else?
All right, we'll move on to the next question
from Moderator.
Is that okay?
[pause] Producer says, "Okay."
"I'm loading several images from disk at basically
the same time, using a background thread,
of course.
However, loading so many images in a matter
of milliseconds will cause gc_for_alloc, causing
noticeable jank.
Anything I can do about that?"
>>Johns: This sounds like a performance question.
Jeff, do you want to take a shot at this?
>>Sharkey: Sure.
Something to realize is even in that background
thread, if you're making that allocation,
you're allocating those bitmaps, if you do
end up having to do this gc_for_alloc, it
could potentially end up locking in the main
thread of your application that's running
the UIV animation if that main thread is also
trying to allocate things.
Really, what you're looking to do here is
you want to really optimize and minimize the
number of allocations you're doing on that
main thread, because what you might find in
this cases is that there's one small, little
allocation that's being exposed to this pause
from the background thread.
If you're able to get the UI animation done
with zero allocations, if you get it all the
way down to zero, you probably wouldn't see
that pause that you're describing.
>>Johns: Also, I'll add that I did a code
lab at Google I/O that did something very
similar to the behavior you're describing.
Specifically, I created a gridview that loads
a bunch of really high resolution images over
and over again.
We walked people through going and finding
all the hotspots in the code, all the things
that would cause-- garbage collection cause--
just general jank.
Everything that was bad.
We'd go and get rid of them one after another.
I think that you can get a link to it from
the Google I/O website.
If not, it is in my own website, tjohns.net/io2012.
I have all the code up there.
Important things: make sure, of course for
performance reasons, you're going to want
to load your images in a background thread,
use AsyncTask or something similar.
Also, make sure that you're reusing all of
your listview elements-- item views, I think's
the word.
Make sure you reuse those.
They do get recycled.
Just make sure that you reuse objects whenever
possible.
On that note, make sure that you're recycling
bitmaps, too.
All the usual things for whenever you're dealing
with bitmap supplier there, because they do
take up a lot of memory.
It's very easy to mess up and cause objects
to be created when they don't need to be.
We've added a lot of hooks there.
Especially, like I said, you can recycle bitmaps
and hang on to things that way.
Actually, I'm trying to--.
Recycling a bitmap actually gets rid of it,
right?
I'm trying to know what the right way to do
it is.
[pause] Do either of you remember the right
way to handle bitmaps?
Like reuse the address space there, for it?
>>Sharkey: I'm trying to remember.
Because there is a release method or a recycle.
>>Johns: Right.
>>Sharkey: But I don't think that's what--
I think recycling actually completely gets
rid of it.
>>Meier: Yeah, recycle gets rid of the address
space completely, or at least--
>>Sharkey: But there is a method where you
can pass it in an existing instance into a
bitmap options as part of uplay.
That's one of the, that's the mechanism that
you're describing, that would allow you to
recycle those existing allocations.
>>Johns: Right.
>>Sharkey: But yeah, the biggest takeaway,
though, is avoid allocations inside of your
drawing, your own draws, because that's what
probably exposing, in this case, to that jank.
>>Johns: Yeah, and you can take a look at
DDMS.
There is an allocation tracker that will show
you where all of your memory is going.
That should give you a pretty strong clue
as to what's causing all of these GC events.
[pause] All right.
>>Meier: Excellent.
I actually have a question from someone on
the invite.
Simon Marquis, who wants to know, "What is
the best choice to play a list of music files
for an app and sometimes interrupts them to
play an effect sound?"
He's listed a couple of ideas.
And also, "What is the--.
Is there a best practice to appropriately
handle the sound but when the screen is off?"
and so on and so forth.
I'm going to jump in and answer that as well.
Yes, SoundPool is the API that you want to
look for, that can best handle that sort of
thing.
A variety of different sound effects and music
within a game.
SoundPool is definitely your friend.
And a media player API should you need it,
but I think you should actually be able to
handle most things within SoundPool by itself.
In terms of the best way to handle sound playing,
our good friends from the Friday Review, Ian
Lewis and Dan Galpin, actually covered this
in some detail at their Google I/O talk Ten
Things All Game Developers Should Know.
Check that out and that will get you some
great advice, particularly how to handle things
like music playback during a lock screen and
when the screen's off and those sorts of things
.
>>Malin: Great answer.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Next question from Moderator: "In the Developer's
Console for one app, the content rating has
the everyone rating disabled.
Next to it, it says, 'This rating option has
been disabled by the Google Play team.'
What could have caused this?"
>>Johns: Well.
[laughs] The answer's actually right there
in front of your face.
It was manually set by a member of the Google
Play team.
We do periodically review apps.
If we notice that an app has an incorrect
rating, it's rated lower than it should be,
we'll go and make a manual adjustment.
That's what you're seeing there.
Basically, they're saying, "Your app contains
some sort of content that makes it unsuitable
for everyone."
>>Meier: In my experience, the most common
cause for that is typically if you're using
some sort of viewer requesting file location
in your app as a permission.
Then there is a minimum level, minimum maturity
level, which has to be, I think it's not below
us, but possibly the next up from that, at
least.
That tends to be the most common case.
It can also be if there is, if your app's
being flagged and the play team are looking
through to make sure that it's compliant with
our content policies and so on.
They may do it manually for those reasons
as well.
But location, I think, is typically the most
common case for this sort of thing.
>>Malin: That's good to know.
Okay.
Great.
Next question from Moderator: "When using
an MHL adaptor to get HDMI out, some apps
like YouTube show different views on the device
display and the HDMI output.
How's that done?
I could not find any API for this.
Is it hardware dependent?"
>>Johns: I did some digging into this.
The answer is there isn't really an API.
This is something that's done by the system.
Whenever, at least, the Google experience
devices detect a video surface that will modify
the HDMI output to go and display the contents
of only that video surface.
It's not something that YouTube is explicitly
doing.
It's something the system is taking care of
automatically.
That said, this behavior is not guaranteed
for all devices.
It's a vendor specific implementation detail.
Other devices might choose to handle HDMI
differently.
But to answer your question, though, if you
want to go and display some custom content
on the other display, there's not really a
way to do it right now.
It's just limited to videos.
[pause]
>>Malin: Okay, thank you.
>>Meier: I have two questions from the live
invite.
One is by, ooh, gosh, that's a name which
is going to be hard for me.
Jazz Lagvankar?
Who would like to know the name of the guy
in the hat.
>>Johns: Ah. [laughs] Hey.
My name is Trevor Johns.
I'm actually on here almost every week, usually
without a hat.
But I'm on the same team as Joe and Reto.
We're all members of the Android Developer
Relations team.
Yeah.
[laughs]
>>Meier: We are trying to implement, possibly,
having a mandatory hat-wearing person in each
of our sessions.
That's usually Dan Galpin on Friday.
But seeing as Dan doesn't sit in on these
sessions, we thought we'd see if Trevor can
sport a hat with the style to which we've
become accustomed.
The next question is from Nicholas Johnson.
He's attempting to develop a rich text component
with buttons for typical rich text editing.
He goes on to say that spans are really difficult
to work with.
The whole thing is a pain, particularly when
you get to things like text selection.
My suggestion here, it will be interesting
to see if you guys agree, but intending to
develop a rich text editing component within
Android is not going to be simple.
You're effectively going to have to recreate
the edit text component from scratch, because
as soon as you try to do things like change
colors midline, add italics and bold, and
so on and so forth, to arbitrary text within
a full control, then you really need to also
take care of how that layout is going to work.
You're effectively going to end up having
to recreate the edit text component from scratch
into something which, within a fairly short
amount of time, is going to look a lot like
a web browser.
Which is in fact how a lot of teams have implemented
this sort of thing, where they do have the
need for rich text editing rather than being
some variation of the edit text.
It's actually a webview within the app.
That, I don't know.
My gut feeling is that that's going to be
the way to go if you want to have something
like anything beyond a really simple marker.
How do you guys feel?
>>Johns: Yeah, I think that that pretty much
covers it.
Rich text is definitely something that's very
difficult to implement.
Webview covers most of it already.
It covers more than you probably want.
It gives you room for expansion.
I want to say most of the time when people
are doing rich text anyway, they're going
to go and want to convert it to HTML, so using
webview takes care of that for you as well.
[pause]
>>Malin: Okay, thank you.
Next question from Moderator: "I've noticed
that some apps that use action bar tabs for
navigation will have the tabs replaced with
the dropdown list when switched to landscape,
when there isn't enough room for tabs.
Is there a way to force it to do that?
Landscape tags are ugly."
Hmm.
Okay.
>>Meier: I think the simple answer, for me,
is to try and use an action bar where possible,
because that's going to already have that
sort of toggle between navigation in--.
It's going to be a dropdown navigation in
portrait mode and in action bar tabs, potentially
in landscape mode.
You can do that variation yourself.
It doesn't necessarily help you for if you
want to have apps which work prior to Honeycomb,
mind you.
But you can certainly try and use that same
sort of model.
In general, my feeling is that your tab post
control isn't great.
This is talking about action bar tabs in general.
Yeah, okay.
Specific to action bar tabs.
That would be my suggestion, to just switch
between them using the spinner in portrait
and the tabs in landscape, or vice versa.
[pause]
>>Malin: All right.
Thank you very much.
Next question from--
>>Ly: Got a Hangout question.
>>Malin: Oh.
Shoot.
>>Meier: Excellent.
>>Ly: "I created a test database and exported
the strings for insert test data, looping
through a string array that were all executing
each command, populate the database.
I couldn't use begin transaction because I
was already in one.
Any advice for creating a test database on
a device?"
>>Sharkey: So you were already in a transaction.
Just to-- I don't know if they're running
this.
It's an Android program, it's an Android app,
and they're attempting to build a prepopulated
database?
That's what it sounds like?
You should be able to create everything inside
of a single transaction on your own.
I'm not sure what the exact--.
It shouldn't be creating in the transaction
on your behalf.
You should be able to begin and manage your
own.
But, yeah.
Without any more detail-- The other thing
he was mentioning is that it's designed to
be generated once.
He's pregenerating the SQLite database to
then ship?
>>Ly: We're getting some clarification.
>>Sharkey: Okay.
>>Ly: It was in the on-create in the open
helper.
>>Sharkey: Okay.
You should be able to--.
Oh, so if it's in the on-create, yeah, you're
right.
You may already be in a transaction at that
point.
If you're looking to test performance, it
should be as good as it's going to get.
The one other thing to potentially look at
is, when you're doing that initial database
setup, you're inserting a lot of data in a
[clattering noise] bulk way.
You may look at creating your indexes after
you've inserted all of the data.
If you create the indexes and then do a whole
bunch of inserts, the database is going to,
may try updating those indexes as your inserting
all of your data.
But if you insert the data first, and then
create the indexes, you may end up with less
work on the database engine side of things.
It may be faster.
[pause]
>>Malin: Okay.
Any response from them?
>>Ly: He said, "Thanks."
>>Malin: Well, if you've got any more questions,
just holler out.
Otherwise we'll move on to the next question
in Moderator: "I have to load an image with
certain restrictions.
For example, I have an 8 megapixel picture
that I want to center crop as a square, rotate,
and maybe scale it.
What's the most efficient way to do this without
creating new bitmaps and recycling the old
ones?"
>>Johns: [laughs] All right.
That's actually a pretty good question.
Jeff, you don't have an answer off the top
of your head for that?
>>Sharkey: I think it depends on if zooming,
if the user can zoom in on the photo while
they're actually working on it.
Because there are some--.
The 8 megapixels, that's a lot of data behind
the scenes.
There's a handful of bitmap factories, the
bitmap options.
You can actually request to have it downsampled.
You can request it to maybe only load every
other pixel.
Instead of an 8 megapixel photo, now you're
working with a 4 megapixel.
There are some options there.
You can load a lower resolution version of
the photo for the user to edit.
It may not be the full quality that they're
expecting, and maybe a lower resolution.
Once you've decided the mutation operations
that the user wants to perform, once they've
chosen the exact rotation, you can go back
and perform a high quality pass of those operations
on the full resolution photo.
That may allow you to make your UI nice and
fast.
You're maybe rotating and manipulating something
lower quality, but then applying it later
against the full resolution image.
>>Meier: That seems like it would be a fairly
good approach for what they're describing
here, because it's fairly coarse-grained stuff.
Center crop, square rotate.
It sounds like they just basically want to
be able to load up any picture in the same
way that you choose a profile pic or something
in a social network.
It just needed to be square, so you just pick
it.
I think in that instance, particularly on
an Android app--.
Even if you are zooming in, as long as it's
good enough to see what the edges are, you
do that and then do a live preview of the
cropped data at a higher res, maybe.
>>Johns: Yeah.
Bitmap Factory has a methods to do most of
that stuff.
The only one I'm not clear about is rotation.
I'm not sure if you can have it rotate for
you.
If that's the case, you might even want to
consider subclassing bitmap Factory and adding
rotation in there, so that way all these operations
are performed as your loading the bitmap.
That would help reduce the-- If you can do
it before you create your bitmap, then you
only have to make one bitmap.
>>Sharkey: Yeah.
The benefit of using those options is that
SKIA, down deep in the native code, is the
one that's doing this downsampling.
Your application doesn't have to allocate
8 megapixels worth of data to store the image
when it's inflated.
It's doing it in a very optimized way under
the hood.
[pause]
>>Malin: Okay, thank you.
Next question from Moderator: "Could you consider
maintaining the Android and support library
artifacts official in Maven central?
Whoever does it now can be a bit slow.
It is a pain in the [pause] ass.
For want of a better word."
>>Johns: Feature request noted.
[chuckles] We've always had a bit of reluctance
to go and support any build systems aside
from Eclipse, just because that's what we
decided that we want to go and spend our time
supporting.
We've always left everything else to the community
to do.
I'll definitely pass that along to do build
team, or the tools team, rather, and let them
know that there's a feature request for that.
That being said, I'm pretty sure they've heard
it before.
It's not the first time I've seen this come
up.
Most likely [pause] it's going to be a bit
of a tough sell, because we have chosen to
go and focus most of our efforts on Eclipse.
But again, I'll make sure they get that feedback.
>>Meier: Related to that as well, we sit right
next to the tools team.
If you guys have questions or requests or
something like that and you'd like to see
us do a Hangout or something like this, specifically
so you guys can talk to them, let us know.
We'll schedule something up.
That is a resource available.
We're not part of that team, so we aren't
necessarily in the best position to answer
those sorts of questions.
>>Malin: All right.
We're getting towards the end, so let's move
on through as quickly as we can.
"Did the Nexus S have its offline voice dictation
and hot word detection disabled in 4.1.1 due
to inadequate audio hardware?
If so, what are your guidelines for testing
if devices running 4.1 meet the baseline for
using the relevant new multimedia APIs?"
>>Johns: I don't think anybody here actually
knows the answer to that, given that none
of us work on the voice team.
This is probably a question better suited
for another office hours where we might have
someone from the voice team on.
But right now, we have no expert who can actually
give you a definitive answer there.
>>Ly: We had a Hangout question.
>>Malin: Go for it.
>>Ly: It's about location updates in a service.
>>Malin: Right.
>>Ly: "Is it better, battery-wise, to sample
updates from network or passive providers
on an interval, or register, on start, a listener
for pending intent and depend on their request
updates parameters for min time and min distance?
>>Meier: Okay, let me see if I understand
this.
So the question is, are they better off poling,
basically getting a last known location?
Or using a, basically asking for a location
based updates at a minimum time and distance?
Is that the gist?
>>Ly: Yeah, it sounds about right.
>>Johns: From what I remember, Get Last Position
is literally returning the last known position,
which is not going to be where the user is,
necessarily, at that given moment.
That is one issue you have to deal with.
>>Meier: Yeah, I would say gen--.
In terms of efficiency, hmm.
In terms of efficiency, I would almost never
recommend a poling approach.
As soon as you're poling for anything, then
you're creating a minimum amount of time where
the device is going to be on, responding to
whatever it is that you're doing at that wake
up.
If you can have anything which is more on
demand, that tends to be a better solution.
I would definitely go with actually creating
a location listener, particularly for the
passive provider.
That way, if there are no apps requesting
location updates, then your app will never
get triggered.
It will go to sleep.
This is really important when the device is
on standby.
If you are doing a poling solution, then you're
still going to wake the device, and you're
still going to check to see when that last
location update was, even if it hasn't changed
for an hour.
Whereas if you've actually got to listener
registered, it's no less efficient than poling
in terms of the work it's doing.
And you have the advantage of being on demand,
so that it's only going to happen as frequently
as any other app is actually making those
location requests.
>>Malin: Okay.
Thank you.
This is an interesting one: "Can you take
another look at my question from last week?
We ran out of time at the end.
The question is 'How to iterate through fragments
in a tab view pager to tell each fragment
the ping data which as been updated by a loader
in the main activity?'" [pause]
>>Meier: I remember hearing the question last
week while I was doing the production.
I don't think we had a great answer then,
and I'm not sure that there really is one.
>>Johns: I still--.
My question is "Why are you trying to do this?"
given that you're only going to have one page
on your view pager visible.
Trying to ask anything else to update while
it's in the background is just a waste of
CPU.
Most UI events don't occur for objects which
are off screen.
Now, that being said, the quest there, the
answer here is basically your typical solution
for communicating with fragments.
I don't think view pager really has anything
to do with it.
It's really a matter of going and sending
a method to all of your fragments.
Register some sort of callback method so that
your activity can just go an deliver a message
to all the known fragments when these events
happen and let them know that they have stale
data which needs to be refreshed at some point
which is appropriate.
>>Sharkey: That's a--, data set observer is
one way that list views, for example, connect
up to cursors.
When you sign a cursor to a cursor loader
and it's bound to a list view, that list view
may be often one of those other fragments.
But the data set observer is the mechanism
by which it knows, "I need to invalidate and
repaint my content."
A strategy like that.
There's data set observer and data set observable.
Those may be a good strategy.
>>Malin: Okay.
>>Ly: We got another Hangout question, and
two more minutes.
>>Malin: All right.
Hangout question.
>>Ly: Last one here.
This person has quite a big database of assets
and dumps it into an SD card.
"Is there a way to access this database directly
to assets so I don't have to duplicate it,
since it's, like, 6 megabytes?"
Does that make sense?
>>Meier: Yes, I think what he wants to do
here is basically-- Similar to the question
which one of the earlier questioners had,
which is "I want to prepopulate a database,
but I don't want to download it in a piecemeal.
I just want to be able to dump it on an SD
card, possibly as part of the installation
process or as a one-off."
Right now, you would have to do-- The usual
way is that you would then have to open that
database, move everything into an SQLite database,
and have the content provider on top of that
to do most operations.
I think the question here is, "Is there a
way you can just point to that database and
say, 'This is my database.
Treat it the same way you would an SQLite
database that you've had opened.'?"
I'm not sure that I have an answer.
I think if it is an SQLite database, then
you probably can.
If it's not, then I'm not sure that that's
possible.
Do you guys have any?
>>Sharkey: SQLite databases, I think you can
open based on an explicit file system path.
You can tell it, "Open this file."
But one thing to note is that if it's living
out on the SD card, anyone could come along,
open it writable, and write any sort of data
in there, which then your app is going to
go consume.
Anything on the SD card is publicly available
for other apps to write into.
The other thing is if you're using it for
persistence, just be aware that sometimes
the SD card can disappear.
But it may also not be--.
The SD card can be of [beeping noise] varying
quality, because they're using a different
file system that's maybe not as resilient.
If you're using the internal file system on
the device, maybe it's like EAFS or ext4,
it's a lot more resilient to changes if the
user pulls the battery out of their device.
>>Meier: Yeah, I think that, I really just
want to emphasize that first point, which
is that it's trivially easy for your SD card
to be, or your shared space to be, unmounted.
If someone plugs it into their computer, boom,
your database disappears.
If they unclick their SD card, boom, your
database is gone.
That adds a certain amount of-- how can I
say?
It doesn't do bad things.
It doesn't do good things to your app.
Suddenly, you have to keep in mind the fact
that your database may just disappear mid
transaction, and figure out how you're going
to recover from that.
And as well, as Jeff said, it can change.
It can be mounted to a computer, then have
all its data changed, then plugged back in.
You need to figure out what you're going to
do with that now.
It's generally not great practice to go that
way.
Granted, if you've got a very large database,
it seems like a reasonable alternative.
But you may actually want to consider storing,
keeping most of that on a server and just
downloading effectively enough data to have
cached a reasonable amount of data to be able
to respond to when you're offline, rather
than storing the entire thing on the phone.
Depending on your usage, that may not work.
>>Johns: Okay.
All right, I think that's it for time.
[laughs]
>>Malin: I think we have run off the end of
the clock.
[pause] So, once again, thank you, everybody,
for stopping in.
We will see you next week.
>>Sharkey: Thanks, everyone.